so uh number one i just have to note
this because it's hilarious
uh alexander ocasio-cortez she keeps
saying that she's a very important
legislator
um it turns out that her own party is
like nope we don't like you very much
it turns out that the dislike for aoc
spans the political aisle
according to ryan sevetter reporting
over at daily wire representative
alexander ocasio-cortez
was overwhelmingly rejected during a
secret ballot vote on friday in her bid
to be seated on a powerful congressional
committee
democrats overwhelmingly voted to give
the seat on house energy and commerce
committee to representative kathleen
rice democrat of new york
instead of aoc in what ended up being a
46 to 13 vote
ouch kathleen rice is a more moderate
democrat who also happens to have spent
her time instead of posting
videos on instagram or on twitch
actually working the democrats
in order to get that slot according to
politico
rice and ocasio-cortez have been
battling behind the scenes for weeks to
secure one of the few open seats on the
exclusive committee which oversees
everything from healthcare policy to
climate issues
tensions spilled out into the open
thursday in a private meeting of the
steering and policy committee where
democrats were forced to choose between
the two members in a tense an
awkward secret ballot vote they still
have secret ballots so you can say that
you don't like aoc anonymously
politico notes that ocasio-cortez was
rejected because many in the party view
her far-left policies as a threat and
also she's been backing all sorts of
challenges to incumbents and they're
like you know what screw you
one member of congress told axios the
vote would have been very different if
it wasn't secret
which suggests democrats are afraid of
aoc publicly but secretly they really
really do not like her at
all like at all so that was a bit of
delicious news
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content